This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness,
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二，绝对真人。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。我将为你剖析精神坚韧的迹象、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
健身方法，以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立复原力的方式。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。名字就是数字2。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
欢迎收听《Look Back At It》播客。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。1984年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚克斯·英格利希。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
84年是一个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人群体来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加梅斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着铠甲？
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就非得这么做。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。在2023年，美国广播公司《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控使人生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动过两次手脚，对吗？我只对测试动过一次手脚。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Alessian and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. You guys know the deal. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱西亚人和迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们在二十几岁时经历的重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。你们懂的。新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来
for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Have you ever found your mind constantly replaying the same thoughts over and over again. Perhaps it's dissecting a past conversation, re-examining a decision that you made, or just endlessly worrying about something that may or may not happen in the future. In those moments, I think it can truly feel like our mind is stuck. It's cycling around the same things, the same loop with no exit, and this isn't just overthinking. It's a specific, often debilitating form of thinking known as rumination.
收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析二十几岁的心理。你是否曾发现自己的大脑在不断地一遍又一遍地回放相同的想法？也许是在剖析过去的一场对话，重新审视你做出的一个决定，或者只是没完没了地担心未来可能发生也可能不会发生的事情。在那些时刻，我认为我们的确会觉得大脑卡壳了。它在同一件事情、同一个循环里打转，却找不到出口，而这不仅仅是过度思考。这是一种特殊的、通常会使人虚弱的思考形式，被称为反刍思维。
And that's what we're going to be dissecting on today's episode. It's actually fairly common for a lot of us to fall into these patterns, often because we somehow think that by replaying certain uncomfortable thoughts or moments, we are somehow going to find a way out of it, or we're going to solve the problem, gain some kind of clarity. Sometimes we even think of rumination as a sign of intelligence, that you're very introspective and reflective, which is probably true, but the rumination isn't what's helping prove that point. It's actually doing the opposite. It's what is getting us stuck in thought loops that shrink our curiosity, and, shrink our perspective of the world. Rumination often really intensifies negative emotions. It fuels anxiety. I know it can leave us feeling mentally exhausted. But the very good news is that there is a way out
而这正是我们今天要剖析的内容。我们中的许多人陷入这种模式其实是很常见的，通常是因为我们不知何故认为，通过反思某些不舒服的想法或时刻，我们就能找到摆脱困境的方法，或者我们能解决问题，获得某种清晰度。有时我们甚至把反思当作智力的象征，认为你非常内省和反思，这可能是真的，但反思并不是证明这一点的东西。它其实适得其反。正是它让我们陷入思维的循环中，缩小了我们的好奇心，也缩小了我们对世界的看法。反刍思维往往真的会加剧负面情绪。它助长了焦虑。我知道这会让我们感到精神疲惫。但非常好的消息是，有一条出路
of this cycle. There is a way to turn left, I guess, when you've always turned right, and that is precisely what I want to break down for you today. What is rumination? What is it actually? How is it connected to intrusive thoughts, things like OCD? What is your brain actually trying to achieve and why can't you stop it from doing so? And also, how do we disengage? How do we find the off switch for thoughts that are just like not only frustrating, but genuinely very annoying when they won't stop running through our head? Stopping rumination, and I know this better than most people, it isn't about suppressing
可以摆脱这个循环。当你总是习惯向右转时，有一种向左转的方法，而这正是我今天要为你详细剖析的。什么是反刍思维？它究竟是什么？它与强迫性思维、像强迫症这样的东西有什么联系？你的大脑到底想达到什么目的，为什么你无法阻止它这样做？还有，我们该如何抽离？我们如何找到那些不仅令人沮丧、而且在脑海中挥之不去时确实十分烦人的想法的关闭开关？停止反刍思维，这一点我比大多数人都要清楚，它不是关于压抑
thoughts. It's not about trying to force yourself to be more positive. I've tried that. I had such a hard time last year with really depressing awful rumination and trying to ignore it or suppress it or constantly distract yourself really gets you nowhere. It's actually the only way out is to really understand why it's happening and to kind of go further into the belly of the beast of rumination and develop metacognitive awareness, develop a better way of relating to your thoughts by staring them straight in the face. And if that sounds weird and complicated and counterintuitive,
想法。它不是关于强迫自己变得更积极。我试过那样做。去年我在应对真正令人沮丧、可怕的反刍思维时经历了一段艰难的时期，试图忽视它、压抑它或不断分散自己的注意力，其实根本无济于事。唯一的出路其实是真正理解它为什么会发生，并有点深入反刍思维的虎穴，培养元认知意识，通过直视你的想法来建立一种与它们相处的新方式。如果这听起来很奇怪、很复杂且反直觉，
I felt the same way when I was introduced to this way of approaching them. But I can personally promise you that it has worked tremendously for me. And I want to share what I've learned through that process and how you can kind of help yourself when rumination just will not turn itself off. So without further ado, let's get into it. I want to start by firstly just dissecting my own experience with rumination because me and rumination have been roommates for a while.
当我接触到这种接近它们的方式时，我也曾有过同感。但我可以个人向你保证，这对我产生了巨大的作用。我想分享我在这个过程中学到的东西，以及当反刍思维怎么也停不下来时，你该如何自我救赎。废话不多说，我们切入正题。我想首先剖析一下我自己的反刍思维经历，因为我和反刍思维当了一阵子的室友。
We have been buddies for a long time. And my brain does not discriminate when it comes down to what we decide to ruminate about. It will take whatever comes through the front door. It will include things like relationship, like my relationship and is something wrong here. Did I say the wrong thing? It includes things around my career, around the podcast, ruminating around whether I did the correct episode, something that I said on an episode, what people are going to think about this or that,
我们做了很长时间的伴侣。而且，当涉及到我们决定反刍什么内容时，我的大脑是不会挑剔的。它会全盘接受任何从前门进来的东西。它包括一些事情，比如关系，就像我的关系以及这里是不是出了什么问题？我是不是说错了话？它包括关于我职业生涯的事情、关于播客的事情，反刍我做的那期节目是否正确，我在某一期节目里说了什么，别人会怎么想这或那，
whether I, you know, annoyed someone by cutting them off on the road, something I did when I was literally like six or seven years old. Rumination for me is just. The way I think about it is like a claw machine at like an arcade where as soon as I, as soon as like it turns on, it's just going to grab anything. Like it doesn't care what it picks up. It just wants to find a source for me to spiral upon and for me to feel anxious about. Like as an example, something that I've been ruminating about so much recently was like
或者我是否，你知道的，在路上超车时惹恼了别人，或者我六七岁时做过的事。对我和反刍思维而言，这只是……我对它的看法就像游乐场里的抓娃娃机，一旦机器启动，它就会抓住任何东西。它不在乎抓起的是什么。它只想找到一个源头让我陷入螺旋式崩溃，让我感到焦虑。举个例子，最近我一直在反刍的一件事是
something that I did almost four years ago now. And I just said something super awkward in a conversation four years ago. and it wouldn't have lasted more than five seconds. And right now, my brain is obsessing over it. I'm up at night thinking about it. I am having dreams about it. And the irony for me within this is that there is nothing I can do about that moment. I can't take that moment back.
我将近四年前做过的一件事。四年前在一次谈话中，我说了句超级尴尬的话。那句话本来持续的时间不会超过五秒钟。而现在，我的大脑却对此执迷不悟。我晚上睡不着觉在想这件事。我甚至做梦都在梦到它。这其中的讽刺之处在于，对于那一刻我无能为力。我无法收回那一刻。
I don't even know some of the people who that moment was in front of. Nothing can change what happened. And yet, the amount that I feel my sense, myself thinking about it, you would think that I had a solution. You would think that I had a game plan or I could find one. And the answer is that I don't. And yet this is a thought pattern. I cannot seem to switch off. I'm sure that you have experienced this. I'm sure that you are listening to me talk about this and be like, yeah, I could apply this as a blueprint to my own life and it would look exactly the same. Rumination is this very interesting thing whereby it's so internal and only we
甚至连那一刻面前都有哪些人我都记不清了。没有什么能够改变已经发生的事情。然而，每当我感觉到自己满脑子都在想这件事时，你都会以为我有什么解决方案。你会以为我有什么应对策略，或者我能找到一个。但答案是，我没有。然而这是一种思维模式。我似乎就是无法关掉它。我确信你也经历过这种情况。我确信你听着我谈论这些会觉得，是的，我可以把这当成我生活的蓝图，它看起来会一模一样。反刍思维是一种非常有趣的东西，它是如此内在，只有我们
can really see it and hear it and experience it and yet there are so many people out there who are having a similar roller coaster spiral whirlpool going on in their head and we never talk about it. The thing that has really helped me though is just having a word to explain what kind of thought this is. because a thought that is based in rumination, a ruminating thought is so much different to any other kind of thought that I have. Just knowing that there is a difference, knowing that these thoughts are special in a way,
自己才能真正看到、听到并体验到它，然而外面有那么多人的脑海里也在经历着类似的山车式螺旋上升和漩涡，而我们却从不谈论它。不过，真正对我有所帮助的是有一个词来解释这是一种什么样想法。因为源于反刍思维的想法，即反刍思维，与我拥有的任何其他类型的想法都有很大不同。仅仅知道它们之间存在差异，知道这些想法在某种程度上是特殊的，
has really, really helped me, knowing that they are a symptom of how my brain works, they're not anything more than that, has really allowed me to integrate them better into, I guess, my day-to-day routine. And I know that sounds weird. but it's allowed me to better look at a thought and say, this is challenging, this is frustrating, this is annoying,
真的对我帮助很大。知道它们只是我大脑运作方式的一种症状，除此之外别无其他，这真的让我能够更好地将它们融入到，我猜是我的日常生活中。我知道这听觉上很奇怪。但这让我能更好地审视一个想法，并说，这很有挑战性，这很让人沮丧，这很烦人，
I can't stop thinking about it, that doesn't necessarily mean that it's significant. And that doesn't necessarily mean that the only way through this thought pattern is by finding a solution. I think the thing I've really come to peace with is that 99% of the time you are not going to solve a rumination or you're not going to solve an obsessive thought by magically coming up with some way to fix it,
我忍不住去想它，但这并不一定意味着它很重要。这也不一定意味着摆脱这种思维模式的唯一途径就是找到解决方案。我认为我真正释怀的一点是，99%的时候，你并不能通过凭空想出某种解决办法来解决反刍或强迫思维，
it's about coming up with a different way to relate to that thought. Rumination is simply put, getting caught up in the why of a problem without moving towards the what now. Rumination wants you to believe that the more you think about something, the closer you'll get to figuring it out. But almost everything we ruminate about, you know, almost everything, like I said, doesn't have a solution. And that's actually the very reason why we ruminate about it.
而是要换一种方式来与这种想法相处。简而言之，反刍思维就是陷入一个问题的“为什么”之中，却不去思考“接下来该怎么办”。反刍思维想让你相信，你对某件事想得越多，你就越接近弄清真相。然而我们反刍的几乎所有事情，你知道的，几乎所有事情，就像我说的，是没有解决方案的。而这实际上正是我们对它进行反刍的原因。
That's why our brain is so obsessive about it. That's why it gets stuck because it is endlessly troubled and endlessly puzzled by this thing that we can't sort out. It's endlessly fascinated by that. A 2000 paper that I was reading on the role of rumination actually found that repetitive thinking very rarely results or improves problem solving. Instead, in almost every single individual they looked at, rumination hindered effective problem solving. It actually gave individuals and participants the illusion of control over a situation, but that illusion actually turned into nothing. They didn't solve problems faster.
这就是为什么我们的大脑对它如此执着。这就是为什么它会卡壳，因为我们被这个无法解决的问题无休止地困扰和难住了。它对此着迷不已。我读过的一篇关于反刍思维作用的2000年论文发现，重复思考极少能产生结果或改善问题解决能力。相反，在他们研究的几乎每一个个体中，反刍思维都阻碍了有效的问题解决。它实际上给个人和参与者制造了一种对局势掌控的错觉，但这种错觉最终化为乌有。他们并没有更快地解决问题。
They weren't more efficient. They didn't find different sides or perspectives on the problem. They often just got stuck in or on one part. path. This passive and cyclical focus, it really depletes your mental resources. It makes it harder for you to think clearly, to think creatively. It's like stirring muddy water. The more you stir, the less clear it becomes. And yet it convinces us time and time again that no, just one more second thinking about it. Just one more day and the solution will become clear. It's honestly, it's like a scam. It's like a pyramid scheme where we're told like the more you invest, the more you're
他们并没有更高效。他们也没有发现问题的不同侧面或视角。他们往往只是卡在某一个路径上。这种被动且循环的专注，极大地消耗了你的心理资源。它让你更难清晰地思考，更难创造性地思考。这就像搅拌浑浊的水。你搅得越多，水就越浑浊。然而它一次又一次地让我们相信，不，再想一秒钟就好。再想一天，解决方案就会变得清晰。老实说，这就像是一个骗局。这就像是一个传销骗局，我们被告知你投入得越多，你得到的就会
to get out. The more time you think about me, the closer you'll get to a solution. And every day, you're waiting for, like, you're waiting for the payout. You're waiting for, like, all the money to rain down on you. And it never does. Rumination is, is like the most elite scam artist. There is. So the question that is probably on your mind is, if it is so bad, why do I do it in the first place? well, I don't think it will come as a surprise that this is often not a deliberate thing. We often genuinely believe that what we are doing is productive. And that's because our brains are built to solve problems. They're built to learn from experience.
越多。你想我的时间越多，你就越接近解决方案。每天，你都在等待，就像你在等待回报一样。你就像是在等待所有的金钱倾盆而下。但它从未发生。反刍思维是，是有史以来最顶级的骗子。所以你心里可能在想的问题是，既然它这么糟糕，我为什么一开始还要这么做？嗯，我想这不会让人感到意外，这通常不是一种蓄意的行为。我们往往真心相信我们在做的事情是富有成效的。这是因为我们的大脑生来就是为了解决问题的。它们生来就是为了从经验中学习。
This is one of the ways that it does it successfully and healthily is by looking at a moment, looking at an experience that was uncomfortable and learning from it, but then moving past it. Rumination occurs when we can, can't move past it, essentially. And so the act becomes less about problem solving and more about problem dissecting without that actually leading to any kind of outcome. Another reason that we ruminate is that we're trying to cope with difficult emotions. When we're feeling sad, anxious, angry, whatever it is, our brains look for ways to manage that discomfort. Obviously, they don't want to
这是它成功且健康地做到这一点的方式之一：审视一个时刻，审视一个令人不舒服的经历并从中吸取教训，然后继续前进。从本质上讲，当我们无法继续前进时，反刍思维就会发生。因此，这种行为与其说是解决问题，不如说是剖析问题，而这并没有带来任何结果。我们反刍的另一个原因是，我们试图应对困难的情绪。当我们感到悲伤、焦虑、愤怒或任何情绪时，我们的大脑就会寻找管理这种不适的方法。显然，它们不想
have the unpleasant feeling. Sometimes rumination becomes a default strategy, even if it's not effective because at least it feels comfortable. And it's a way to stay internally focused rather than face the discomfort directly or by engaging with the outside world. It allows us to deal with the problem completely within us. And that means we don't have to face, you know, perhaps a feeling of embarrassment or shame with sharing our anxieties. We don't have to face, yeah, whatever the outside world has to say about our problem. Of course, another reason why we ruminate is that a lot of us really struggle with uncertainty. I know I do. I think it's one of my biggest floor. It's like genuinely it's my biggest floor. It's a huge reason why I think I'm so
有这种不愉快的感觉。有时，反刍思维会成为一种默认策略，即使它并不有效，因为至少它感觉很舒服。这是一种保持内在专注的方式，而不是直接面对不适，或者通过与外界接触来应对。它允许我们在完全内在的情况下处理问题。这意味着我们不必面对，你知道的，分享我们的焦虑时可能会感到的尴尬或羞耻感。我们不必面对，是的，外界对我们的问题有何看法。当然，我们反刍的另一个原因是我们中的很多人确实在应对不确定性时举步维艰。我知道我就是这样。我认为这是我最大的缺点之一。这真的可以说是我的最大缺点。
impatient. If something feels unresolved or ambiguous, our mind might ruminate in an endless loop to try and find some kind of definitive answer or a feeling of closure that will give us something concrete to end with. Something resolute to put us. stop to the spiral. What we don't realize is that very rarely will that answer actually be satisfying once we get it. It's basically just a proxy. The pursuit of an answer is a lie. There normally isn't one. Consider the example of someone being cheated on. You might become, you might obsessively ruminate about why. You want to know why. Why did you do that to me? Why wasn't I enough? Why was this person better than me.
这是我认为我如此缺乏耐心的巨大原因。如果事情感觉悬而未决或模棱两可，我们的大脑可能会陷入无休止的循环中进行反刍，试图找到某种明确的答案或一种尘埃落定的感觉，从而给我们一个具体的结局。一个坚决的句号，来结束这种螺旋。我们没有意识到的是，一旦我们得到了这个答案，它很少会真正令人满意。它基本上只是一个替代品。对答案的追求是一个谎言。通常根本没有答案。以一个被劈腿的人为例。你可能会开始，你可能会痴迷地反刍为什么。你想知道为什么。你为什么要那样对我？为什么我不够好？为什么这个人比我更好？
Whatever answer your ex gives you for why they did it, why it happened, why it wasn't your fault, it's still going to hurt the same amount because the pain isn't in the reason, it's in the fact that it happened, right? But whilst there's still this possibility of an answer and of closure, we hold on to that idea. It's kind of like a life buoy, like a life vest. We hold on to the idea that all the pain we're going through could simply be explained. away because that seems like a much nicer idea than, you know, the real outcome and the real
无论你的前任给你什么答案来解释他们为什么这样做，为什么会发生这种事，为什么这不是你的错，它带来的痛苦依然会是一样的，因为痛苦不在于原因，而在于它确实发生了，对吧？但是，当仍然存在得到答案和获得 closure（释怀）的可能时，我们就会紧紧抓住这个想法。这有点像救生圈，就像救生衣。我们紧紧抓住这样一种想法，即我们正在经历的所有痛苦都可以简单地解释
thing that will happen, which is that we have to work through this on our own and we have to work through this, through this knowing that no answer is ever going to satisfy the fact that what happened to us was just painful. You know, an answer is always going to be futile, but we can't give up on the fantasy of an easy solution. You know, like any behavior, the more, the more we engage in something, the more we practice it, the better our brain really gets at it. You know, the more you practice pitching a ball, the more you practice painting, the more you practice solving a Rubik's cube. These are all very weird examples, but you get what I mean, the better our brain gets at doing it. Same with rumination. The neural pathways associated
清楚，因为这似乎比真正的结果和真正将要发生的事情要好得多，真正的结果是：我们必须独自度过这一关，我们必须带着“没有任何答案能够弥补我们所遭受的痛苦”这种认知来度过这一关。你知道的，答案永远都是徒劳的，但我们无法放弃对一个简单解决方案的幻想。你知道的，就像任何行为一样，我们对某件事投入越多，练习得越多，我们的大脑就真的越擅长它。你知道的，你练习投球越多，你练习画画越多，你练习解魔方越多。这些都是非常奇怪的例子，但你明白我的意思，我们的大脑就越擅长做这件事。反刍思维也是如此。相关的神经通路
with these repetitive thoughts just get stronger and stronger over time. It's a very famous saying neurons that fire together wire together, it's called long-term potentiation, this is what is happening when you can't stop ruminating, when it feels like that is the first line of defense against any problem that you do. You think about it enough until hopefully it doesn't hurt anymore. Over time, it can become an automatic response to stress, to a negative mood, to minute challenges. You don't even consciously choose to do it. It's just your brain going down the most well-worn path that it can because that is the easiest way to move forward. So whilst rumination often starts with seemingly good intentions,
这些重复的想法随着时间推移会变得越来越强烈。有一句非常著名的名言：“神经元一起放电，就会连接在一起。”这被称为长时程增强（LTP）。这就是当你无法停止反刍思维时发生的情况，当它感觉像是你对抗任何问题的第一道防线时。你会不断地思考它，直到它不再那么痛苦为止。随着时间推移，它可能变成一种对压力、消极情绪和微小挑战的自动反应。你甚至不是有意识地选择这样做。这只是你的大脑沿着它能走的最熟悉、最省力的路径前行，因为那是前进最简单的方式。因此，虽然反刍思维通常始于看似良好的意图，
to solve, to cope, to find closure, to understand, it quickly turns into a self-perpetuating cycle that keeps us really stuck. You've really got to recognize these underlying motivations that our brain is rolling out in order to be able to gently redirect your thoughts in the future. something I haven't mentioned that I think is really crucial just to quickly add in here. Rumination and OCD are often very linked as well. Rumination can sometimes manifest in a particularly intense form under OCD. In OCD, rumination isn't just, you're not just dwelling on everyday worries.
即为了解决问题、应对挑战、找到结论、理解事情，但它很快就会演变成一个自我延续的循环，让我们深陷其中。你必须认识到大脑背后这些潜在的动机，以便将来能够温柔地重塑你的思维。有一件事我之前没提到，我认为极其重要，需要在这里快速补充一下。反刍思维和强迫症（OCD）通常也紧密相连。在强迫症的影响下，反刍思维有时会以一种极其强烈的方式表现出来。在强迫症中，反刍思维不仅仅是你停留在日常的担忧上。
The thoughts become intrusive, they become unwanted, and they're highly distressing. and these thoughts often clash with someone's deeply held values and their sense of self. For example, someone with OCD, you know, they might endlessly ruminate, obsessively ruminate over whether they've caused someone harm. If they've left the stove on, they might be plagued by really disturbing unwanted thoughts of a violent nature, of a sexual nature, despite having no desire to act on them. They just can't help themselves. A key distinction in OCD compared to just plain old rumination is this compulsive element.
这些想法变得具有侵入性、不受欢迎且高度令人痛苦。这些想法往往与一个人深信不疑的价值观和自我认知发生冲突。例如，患有强迫症的人，你知道的，他们可能会无休止地、强迫性地反刍自己是否伤害了别人。如果他们忘了关炉子，他们可能会被那些暴力性质、性质的、真正令人不安且不受欢迎的想法所困扰，尽管他们根本没有去做的欲望。他们只是无法控制自己。强迫症与单纯的反刍思维的一个关键区别就在于这种“强迫”元素。
An intrusive thought is often followed by an action that attempts to soothe. So seeking reassurance, double-checking every single switch in your house, washing your hands. But rumination itself could actually become the mental compulsion, right? Rumination is both at the beginning and the end of a mental, an unhealthy mental loop. So the only way that you find yourself being able to feel less distressed by the fact that you can't stop thinking about something is by thinking about it more. This is often known as purely obsessional OCD as well. The thought is both the obsession and ironically it's also the compulsion.
一个闯入性的想法之后，通常会跟着一个试图寻求抚慰的行动。比如寻求安慰、双重检查屋里的每一个开关、洗手。但反刍思维本身实际上可能变成一种精神上的强迫行为，对吧？反刍思维既是不健康精神循环的开始，也是它的结束。因此，你唯一能让自己对“无法停止思考某事”这一事实感到不那么痛苦的方法，就是去想它更多。这通常也被称为纯强迫型强迫症。这种想法既是强迫观念，讽刺的是，它也是强迫行为。
It's kind of like what we were talking about before, you know, thinking about something constantly might actually be kind of soothing. it kind of offers temporary relief. Even if later down the line, it becomes incredibly difficult to undo, even if later down the line, it becomes incredibly painful. So rumination has a lot of ties to OCD. It also has a lot of ties to depression. There is a specific form of rumination known as depressive rumination that is a core feature in the onset maintenance and recurrence of a depressive episode.
这有点像我们之前谈到的，你知道的，不断思考某事实际上可能会让人觉得有点安慰。它能提供暂时的解脱。即使在后期，这种习惯变得极难根除，即使在后期，它变得极其痛苦。因此，反刍思维与强迫症有着很深的联系。它与抑郁症也有很多联系。有一种特定形式的反刍思维被称为“抑郁性反刍”，它是抑郁症发作、持续和复发的核心特征。
Basically, depressive rumination really focuses on self-blame. It focuses on perceived inadequacies, past failures, feelings of hopelessness. And unlike general rumination, which is often about a specific problem, depressive rumination often has a very broad focus. It's dwelling on questions like, am I a bad person? What's wrong with me? Why don't things grow right for me? My life is pointless.
基本上，抑郁性反刍真正关注的是自我责备。它聚焦于感到的不足、过去的失败和绝望感。与通常针对特定问题的广义反刍不同，抑郁性反刍往往具有非常广泛的焦点。它纠结于诸如“我是一个坏人吗？”“我怎么了？”“为什么我的生活总是不顺？”“我的生命毫无意义”之类的问题。
You know, this form of rumination often shifts attention inward, away from the external world. It's not about conversations. It's not about specific events. It's about who you are as an individual. So whilst in this episode, we really are focusing more on non-clinical forms of rumination, it is important to know that the underlying mechanisms
你知道，这种形式的反刍思维通常将注意力转向内部，远离外部世界。它关心的不是对话，也不是特定的事件，而是作为个体的你究竟是谁。因此，虽然在本期节目中我们确实更专注于非临床形式的反刍思维，但了解其潜在机制还是很重要的。
of how we engage with our thoughts do look differently when they are in the context of certain mental health problems, like OCD, like depression. They take on a more severe, element. And so if that severe element of this is what you're experiencing, it's really important that you reach out, you get help. I want to be incredibly clear with you right now. People can actually help you with this. You might not think they can because you've dealt with it by yourself for so long.
我们与想法互动的方式在某些心理健康问题的背景下看起来确实有所不同，比如强迫症、抑郁症。它们会带有一种更加严重的色彩。因此，如果你正在经历这种严重的情况，向外求助并获得帮助是非常重要的。我现在想向你明确一点：人们实际上是可以帮你解决这个问题的。你可能觉得他们做不到，因为你一个人独自应付了太久。
People, like there are people out there who train many, many years just to help you not have obsessive ruminating thoughts. I promise you, you will see a difference. It will get better if you seek out professional help. Like, I can almost promise that for you. There is someone out there who can help you with this. Okay, we're going to take a short break, but when we come back, I want to talk about how we can successfully overcome chronic rumination
人们，外面有许多人经过了多年的专业训练，只为了帮助你摆脱强迫性的反刍思维。我向你保证，你会看到改变的。如果你寻求专业帮助，情况就会好转。就像，我几乎可以为你打包票。外面一定有人能帮你。好了，我们要进行短暂的休息，但等我们回来后，我想谈谈如何成功克服慢性反刍思维，
using some really powerful psychological tools you may not have heard of. So stay with us. We're going to return after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
通过一些你可能没听说过的非常强大的心理学工具。所以请继续收听。我们在短暂停顿后回来。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在这个奇特现代世界中建立心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
我们曾经深信植物油天生具有致炎性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的 Two Percent。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。
And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care.
规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·西恩菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《闺蜜》的新一季中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯约会过。我感觉自己像是被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。
So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼不。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。
Remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个时刻，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks on. I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
包括最近一期节目中，马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）大谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊当天的可卡因，只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience
我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《The Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域的十多年经验，
in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it,
以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里ップ·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，而我们却依然在追逐，
and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
而且我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的竞赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. All right. Here's the deal. Here's the deal.
那是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们在我的新播客《The Hard Way》中就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。好了。事情是这样的。事情是这样的。
If you want to gain mastery over your rumination, you've firstly got to understand this thing called metacognition. Not meta as in Facebook or Instagram, meta is in beyond above higher. So metacognition, this was a phrase coined by the psychologist called John Flavel back in the 1970s. And essentially what it means is our ability to think about our thinking. It's something that makes us. uniquely human. It's something that I don't think any other species can do. Essentially, metacognition is your ability to be aware of and understand your own thought processes in a way that is quite detached, in a way that is observing rather than engaging, in a way that lets you
如果你想掌握并控制你的反刍思维，你首先必须理解一个叫做“元认知”的概念。这里的“元”不是指 Facebook 或 Instagram，而是指超越、高于、更高。所以“元认知”这个词是由心理学家约翰·弗拉维尔（John Flavell）在20世纪70年代创造的。从本质上讲，它的意思是：我们思考自己思考过程的能力。这是使我们成为独一无二人类的特质。我认为没有任何其他物种能够做到这一点。本质上，元认知就是你意识到并理解自己思维过程的能力，这种方式是相当超然的，是观察而非沉浸其中的，是一种让你
step back and kind of see your thoughts and see the thought patterns that you are having, almost as if they are an object that's moving on a screen or someone else, acting something out. When you're ruminating, you are often incredibly, deeply inside of your thoughts. This is a problem because they feel like they are everything and that they are the final truth about your life and that they are, they dictate everything. When the truth is, if you can engage in metacognition, you're able to step outside of that and see that you are not your thoughts.
退后一步，审视自己的想法以及正在经历的思维模式，就好像它们是屏幕上移动的物体，或者是别人在表演一样。当你处于反刍状态时，你通常会非常深地陷在自己的想法里。这是一个问题，因为它们感觉就像是全部，它们是你生活的最终真理，并且它们决定了一切。但事实是，如果你能进行元认知，你就能够跳出那个圈子，看到“你并不是你的想法”。
You just have thoughts. those two things are separate. You are not your thoughts, you just have thoughts. This distinction is so vital. It's so vital in interrupting the cycle of rumination because it stops you from getting overly invested in something just because you think it. It's like just because you feel like a failure doesn't mean that you are a failure. Just because you feel like something terrible is going to happen doesn't mean that it does. Just because you think that someone else thinks something about you doesn't make it true. Your brain doesn't have that kind of power to control outcomes and to control other people's
你只是拥有想法。这两者是分开的。你不是你的想法，你只是有想法。这种区别至关重要。这对于打断反刍思维的循环至关重要，因为它能阻止你仅仅因为“你这样想”而过分投入其中。就像仅仅因为你觉得自己是个失败者，并不意味着你真的就是个失败者。仅仅因为你觉得会有可怕的事情发生，并不意味着它就会发生。仅仅因为你认为别人对你有什么看法，并不代表那就是真的。你的大脑没有那种控制结果和控制他人
thoughts to control the future. It's not a mind reader. It's not a future reader. That is the important thing that metacognition allows us to do. It allows us to break the loop between feeling like we are our thoughts and knowing that actually we aren't. This kind of cognitive distance, it really empowers us. It gives us the choice to respond to a thought differently rather than being controlled by it. A very prominent therapeutic approach that specifically uses metacognition, it's in the name, it's called metacognitive
想法、控制未来的能力。它不是读心者。它也不是未来预测器。这就是元认知允许我们做到的重要事情。它让我们能够打破这种循环：把“我们就是我们的想法”转变为“实际上我们并不是”。这种认知距离赋予了我们力量。它赋予了我们以不同方式回应想法的选择权，而不是被想法所控制。一种非常突出的、明确运用元认知的治疗方法，正如其名，被称为“元认知疗法”。
therapy. It was developed by a professor known as Adrian Wells. The aim of this therapy is basically to directly address rumination and worry by focusing on how we think or our metacognitive beliefs rather than simply the content of our thoughts. So the perspective of this approach is that psychological distress isn't caused by negative thoughts themselves. You're not actually scared of the thought. It's how we react to those thoughts that is really what's concerning us, particularly the fact that we feel we can't not think about something.
它由亚瑟·韦尔斯（Adrian Wells）教授开发。这种疗法的目的是通过关注我们如何思考（即我们的元认知信念），而不是简单地关注我们想法的内容，来直接解决反刍思维和担忧。因此，这种方法的观点是，心理痛苦并不是由消极想法本身引起的。你其实并不是害怕那个想法。是我们对那些想法的反应才真正让我们感到困扰，尤其是我们觉得“自己无法不去想某件事”这一点。
think about it. No matter how scary a thought is, if you could just decide not to think about it, it wouldn't be that scary to you. It's the fact that you don't feel like you can control how you feel and how you think about a thought that turns it into a ruminating thought, that turns it into a repetitive thought. So what we have to practice is kind of moving from being a passenger on a train of thoughts to becoming the driver. A driver who is, capable of applying the brakes, capable of changing tracks. And this ability to observe and detach, unfortunately, is not something we're born with, but it is a skill that we can develop through deliberate practice,
去想它。无论一个想法多么可怕，如果你能决定不去想它，它对你来说也就没那么可怕了。正是因为你觉得自己无法控制对一个想法的感觉和思考方式，才把它变成了一种反刍思维，变成了一种重复的想法。所以我们必须练习从思维列车上的乘客转变为司机。一个能够踩刹车、能够变换轨道的司机。不幸的是，这种观察和超然的能力并不是我们生来就有的，但它是我们可以通过刻意练习来培养的一项技能，
interrupting yourself when you realize you're getting into that pattern. And importantly, not letting yourself fall into a negativity bias through rumination. So essentially, not always thinking that the worst case scenario is going to happen. not always predicting that people are thinking the worst of you. This involves being able to say, okay, I'm ruminating and I'm obsessive about this thought and I'm worried about this thing because I think something bad has happened or will happen. Is that the only possible outcome here?
当你意识到自己陷入这种模式时打断自己。重要的是，不要让自己因为反刍思维而陷入负面偏见。本质上，不要总是认为最坏的情况一定会发生。不要总是预测别人都在往最坏的方面看你。这需要你能够说：“好吧，我正在反刍，我对这个想法很执着，我担心这件事是因为我觉得发生了或将要发生什么坏事。这真的是这里唯一的可能结果吗？”
What are the chances that the worst case scenario happens every single time to me? Historically, you know, if you look back at other times that you've ruminated and think have turned out positively, it's really helpful to remind yourself of those things. It's also really helpful to say, this is one outcome. I'm going to give myself a list of 500 other outcomes that could be more positive. Another way that I really try and control my ruminating thoughts, because I get really bad rumination around death sometimes, is that when I feel myself get into a spiral, I go into my notes up and I explain to myself why this is happening.
每次最坏情况都发生在我身上的几率到底有多大？从历史来看，你知道的，如果你回想一下过去其他那些你曾反刍过、但后来结果证明是积极的事情，提醒自己这些会非常有用。对自己说“这只是一种结果”也非常有用。我要给自己列出500种可能更积极的其他结果。我试图控制反刍思维的另一种方法——因为我有时会对死亡产生非常严重的反刍——是当我感到自己陷入思维螺旋时，我会打开备忘录应用，向自己解释为什么会发生这种情况。
I get super scientific about it. I write down, you know, this is not, this is just anxiety. This thought isn't more real than any other thought that I'm having. It's just my anxiety. Just because I'm thinking it doesn't mean it's real. I know this is just how my brain works. I know that it just doesn't have all the information. I know that I'm just dealing with uncertainty and that my brain's solution for dealing with uncertainty is just to make me so scared that I feel prepared. Having that like clinical precision and rationalism to why I am feeling fearful or why I can't stop ruminating is really important. And as long as I am getting worked up over a thought that I'm ruminating over, I will keep writing in my notes app explaining to myself like a teacher, like a parent,
我会用极其科学的方式来对待它。我写下来，你知道的，这不对，这只是焦虑。这个想法并不比我脑海中的任何其他想法更真实。这只是我的焦虑。这并不意味着我在想它它就是真的。我知道这只是我大脑的工作方式。我知道它并没有掌握所有的信息。我知道我只是在应对不确定性，而我大脑应对不确定性的解决方案就是让我感到如此害怕，以至于我觉得自己做好了准备。拥有这种临床般的精确性和理性主义，来解释为什么我会感到害怕，或者为什么我无法停止反刍，这真的非常重要。只要我还在为一个我正在反刍的想法而烦躁不安，我就会继续在我的笔记应用里写东西，像老师、像家长一样向自己解释，
why this is happening, that this thought doesn't have any more merit just because it feels big, bad and scary. It's just that my brain's giving it more attention and I'm not that thought and it doesn't make that thought more real. Building on metacognition, we also have to understand a concept called cognitive fusion. This is a key principle in acceptance and commitment therapy, which is a type of therapy that really helps people manage their thoughts and feelings, rather than trying to change them directly. Again, trying to change how we feel about our thoughts, not the thoughts necessarily. Cognitive fusion basically describes a state where we become fused with our thoughts,
为什么会发生这种情况，这个想法并没有因为感觉重大、糟糕和可怕而更有价值。只是我的大脑给予了它更多的关注，而我不是那个想法，这并没有让那个想法变得更真实。在元认知的基石上，我们还必须理解一个叫做认知融合的概念。这是接纳承诺疗法（ACT）中的一个核心原则，这是一种真正帮助人们管理自己的想法和感觉，而不是试图直接改变它们的疗法。再说一次，是试图改变我们对想法的感觉，而不一定是想法本身。认知融合基本上描述了一种我们与想法融为一体的状态，
meaning that we treat them as literal truths as commands, as deeply embedded parts of who we are. When we are fused with a thought, we often lose sight of the fact that it's just a collection of words or images passing through our mind. We think that it's more important than that. For example, if you have the thought, I'm an embarrassment or I'm cringe, and you're fused with that thought because it's happened and run through your head so many times, you experience it almost as a reality about yourself. this often leads to the fact that we react directly to the thought by withdrawing, by giving up, rather than choosing to question it. Just because you have a bad thought about yourself or about a situation doesn't mean you can't have a better thought about yourself or a situation. That initial negative thought has come from you.
这意味着我们将它们视为绝对真理、指令，视为我们骨子里的一部分。当我们与一个想法融合时，我们往往会忽视这样一个事实，即它只是一堆穿过我们大脑的词语或图像。我们认为它比这更重要。例如，如果你脑子里冒出“我是个累赘”或“我太尴尬了”这样的想法，而且你与这个想法融为一体，因为这种事已经发生过并在你脑海中闪过了无数次，你几乎会把它当成关于你自己的现实。这往往会导致我们直接对这个想法做出反应，通过退缩、放弃，而不是选择去质疑它。你对你自己或某种情况产生了一个糟糕的想法，并不意味着你不能对你自己或某种情况产生一个更好的想法。最初那个负面的想法是你产生的，
A better one can come from you as well. In the context of rumination, you know, cognitive fusion is really what is keeping are strapped. When we are fused with repetitive, negative, or uncomfortable thoughts like, I'm unlovable or I'm stupid or whatever it is, these thoughts feel like reality. The opposite of cognitive fusion is cognitive diffusion. This is what we want to pursue instead. And it involves seeing thoughts for what they truly are. They're not facts. They're just your brain creating ideas and creating situations and creating thoughts that challenge you and that feel real to you even though objectively they might not be in some ways it's beneficial it's our
一个更好的想法同样也可以由你产生。在反刍的语境下，你知道，认知融合确实是束缚我们的东西。当我们与重复的、消极的或不舒服的想法（比如“我没人爱”或“我很蠢”之类的话）融合时，这些想法感觉就像现实一样。认知融合的反面是认知解离。这才是我们想要追求的。它涉及将想法看作它们真正的样子。它们不是事实。它们只是你的大脑在创造想法、创造情境、创造那些挑战你、让你觉得真实的想法，即使在客观上它们可能并非如此。在某些方面它是 bénéfique 的，它是我们的
brain trying to prepare ourselves it's whatever for whatever reason it's happening the easiest way to intercept it is to say actually what if i chose just to not believe this thing What if I chose to just not agree? I'm allowed to disagree with my thoughts. They're mine. They're my freaking thoughts. I'm going to disagree. I want to talk about another exercise here that I do,
大脑试图让我们做好准备，不管出于什么原因，拦截它的最简单的方法就是说：“实际上，如果我选择不相信这个东西会怎么样？”如果我选择不同意呢？我有权不同意我自己的想法。它们是我的。它们是我该死的想法。我要说不。我想在这里谈谈我做的另一个练习，
that I do all the time that helps me a lot with this, which is when I have a really bad rumination spiral and I can't stop thinking about something, I tell myself that that thought hasn't come from me, it's come from someone else. Specifically, this other person in my brain, called Brian. Brain, Brian, it's a play on words. Brian, like my brain is like the rational good part of me who I love and who I enjoy and who is joyful and gives me the capacity to think and be open. Brian,
我一直都在做，这对我很有帮助。每当我陷入非常糟糕的反刍恶性循环，无法停止思考某件事时，我会告诉自己，那个想法不是来自我，而是来自别人。具体来说，是我脑海中的另一个人，名叫布赖恩（Brian）。脑子，布赖恩（Brain, Brian），这是个双关语。布赖恩就像我大脑中理性、善良的那部分，我爱他，我享受他，他充满快乐，赋予我思考和敞开心扉的能力。布赖恩，
on the other hand, is the parts of me that are cruel, that are obsessive, that are mean and nasty to myself. Brian is like the little devil on my shoulder. And any time I really am getting like stuck in a thought, what I always say is like, oh my God, Brian is being such a dick right now. Brian is really like getting in the way. Brian is being a real nuisance. Brian is really letting the team down. And it helps me create a cognitive distance between myself and a thought. Stephen Hayes wrote this book called Get Out of Your Mind and Into Your Life.
另一方面，则是我身上残忍、强迫、刻薄、对自己很不好的那部分。布赖恩就像我肩头的小恶魔。每当我真正陷入一个想法无法自拔时，我总是会说：“天哪，布赖恩现在真是个混蛋。”布赖恩真的很碍事。布赖恩真是个讨厌鬼。布赖恩真的让团队失望了。这有助于我在自己和一个想法之间建立认知距离。斯蒂芬·海斯（Stephen Hayes）写过一本书叫《走出你的头脑，进入你的生活》（Get Out of Your Mind and Into Your Life），
and he talks about a similar exercise where you can also try and change a thoughts presentation. So you can imagine that your inner critic speaks in a really silly cartoon voice. Or you can like sing your negative thoughts as a little song. You can imagine, you know, that it's not Brian who's saying these negative things. It's your childhood bully or some person that you really don't respect. So if it's coming from someone you don't respect, you feel like, you don't have to listen to it as much. You're just trying to change the presentation of this voice. So it's not godlike, it doesn't feel like it's reality, it's just, you know, some creepy little
他在书中谈到了一个类似的练习，你还可以尝试改变想法的呈现方式。所以你可以想象你的内在批判者用一种非常滑稽的卡通声音说话。或者你可以像唱一首小曲一样把你的负面想法唱出来。你可以想象，这并不是布赖恩在说这些负面东西，而是你童年时的霸凌者或者你根本不尊重的人。所以如果它是来自一个你不尊重的人，你会觉得，你没必要听那么多。你只是在试图改变这个声音的呈现方式。所以它不是神一般的存在，它感觉不像现实，它只是，你知道的，某个角落里令人毛骨悚然的小
person in the corner. It's just some like weird little bully that lives in your brain. You can also try and visualize your thoughts as objects. So you could picture thoughts as things that are floating down a river, a cloud drifting across the sky, something that you can just observe, acknowledge and then move on from. A 2017 meta-analysis actually found that this technique of observation or observing your thoughts of turning them into something physical, giving them a sense of distance, it's actually incredibly powerful. The reason that they said it's powerful is because so many other ways of approaching
人。它只是住在你大脑里的某种奇怪的小恶魔。你还可以试着把你的想法可视化为物体。所以你可以把想法想象成漂浮在河面上的东西、一片在天空中飘荡的云，你可以去观察、承认然后放下的东西。2017年的一项元分析实际上发现，这种观察的技术——观察你的想法，把它们变成某种物理的东西，给它们一种距离感——实际上具有不可思议的力量。他们说它强大的原因是因为处理
rumination tells you that you're not allowed or that you shouldn't have negative thoughts. These perspectives tell you that it's normal. You just need to make peace with them. Another thing that I imagine when I have a lot of ruminating thoughts or intrusive thought is I think about this thought being like someone who's in my home. Like my brain is like this big, beautiful, you know, four-story house and it's got all this comfy furniture and someone comes in and it's this thought.
反刍的许多其他方法都告诉你，你是不被允许的，或者你不应该有负面想法。这些观点告诉你这是正常的。你只需要和它们和平相处。当我有很多反刍想法或侵入性想法时，我脑海中浮现的另一件事是，我把这个想法想象成一个住在我家里的人。就像我的大脑是一栋巨大、美丽、你知道的、四层的房子，里面有所有舒适的家具，然后有人进来了，就是这个想法。
And I can like really freak out about this thought and be like, oh my God, what are you doing here? Like, what are you doing in my house? and like panic and lock all the doors and run around. And that's going to really like frustrate the thought and make it feel more emboldened to be in my house. Or I can open the door to the thought and say, oh, hey, you're here. Come have a cup of coffee. Like, come sit down with me and you can just potter around. Like, I know you're in the house.
我可以对这个想法大惊小怪，比如：“天哪，你在这里干什么？你在我家里干什么？”然后恐慌、锁上所有的门、到处乱跑。这真的会惹恼那个想法，让它觉得更有胆量呆在我的家里。或者我可以为这个想法打开门，然后说：“噢，嘿，你来啦。来喝杯咖啡吧。来和我坐在一起，你可以随便转转。我知道你在家里。”
I'm not going to be like shocked when you show up. I'm just going to keep living my life. And I'm not going to let you like ruin it. You're welcome to walk around and sometimes I'll probably even forget that you're, you're there. Do you see what I'm saying? Like basically you want to find a way that you're not like scared of the fact that you're ruminating. You're just able to detach from it. A closely related tool as well if you haven't already guessed is mindfulness. I feel like mindfulness is so often misunderstood. People think that it's like meditation or just emptying your mind. People think that it's boring.
“当你出现时，我不会感到震惊。我会继续过我的生活。我不会让你毁了它。欢迎你到处走走，有时我甚至可能会忘记你在那里。”你明白我的意思吗？基本上，你想找到一种方法，让你不再对自己在反刍这件事感到害怕。你能够从中抽离出来。如果你还没猜到的话，一个密切相关的工具就是正念。我觉得正念经常被误解。人们认为它就像冥想或只是放空大脑。人们认为它很无聊。
However, mindfulness is really just the awareness. that arises through paying attention on purpose and being in the present moment without applying judgment to the present moment. That is the definition that it was given by the Center for Mindfulness and Medicine, like the preeminent Center for Mindfulness. And I like that definition so much more. It's basically just the art of honing in on your senses and bringing awareness to what is happening right now, whether it's,
然而，正念实际上只是通过刻意关注并在当下保持存在，而不对当下做出判断而产生的觉知。那是正念与医学中心，也就是那个卓越的正念中心给出的定义。我更喜欢那个定义。它基本上就是磨练你的感官并将觉知带到此时此刻正在发生的事情上的艺术，无论是，
in your body, the sounds around you, the simple act of breathing. Now, how does this help rumination? Rumination, by its very nature, pulls you away from the present into like these really dark, scary caves in your mind. It may also drag you into the past by asking you to replay events or things that embarrassed you, or it propels you into the future, worrying about what might happen. either way, it's not present-based.
在你的身体里，你周围的声音，简单的呼吸行为。那么，这如何帮助解决反刍呢？反刍，就其本质而言，会将你从当下拉开，拉进你脑海中那些真正黑暗、可怕的洞穴里。它还可能会通过要求你重播让你尴尬的事件或事情把你拖回过去，或者它会把你推向未来，担心可能会发生的事情。无论哪种方式，它都不是基于当下的。
Mindfulness, on the other hand, is this light attachment to the present moment. And when we kind of walk into that channel of light, we're able to come back. It's like your brain is a child who keeps running away. And you're like, oh my God, like, my child is running away and you're like, you can freak out. You just have to keep bringing them back until they stop, right? you just have to be like, all right, come on, come back now, come back now, back to the present moment, back to the present moment, back to the present moment, you can keep trying to run away, but like, I'm faster than you, I will get you. That's what you have to do with your brain.
另一方面，正念是对当下的一种轻度依恋。当我们走进那道光芒的通道时，我们就能回来。这就像你的大脑是一个不断逃跑的孩子。你会想：“天哪，我的孩子在逃跑。”你会惊慌失措。你只需要不断把他们带回来，直到他们停下来，对吧？你只需要说：“好吧，来吧，现在回来，现在回来，回到当下，回到当下，回到当下，你可以继续逃跑，但是，我比你快，我会抓到你的。”这就是你对你的大脑必须做的事情。
Mindfulness is actually more powerful than rumination because it's deliberate. Rumination isn't always intentional. Mindfulness always is. It's kind of like there's a hierarchy, right, in your brain of thoughts that take priority and a deliberate intentional thought is always going to come out on top. Mindfulness is like being the parent, the parent to your brain, the parent who brings you back whenever you were running away, whenever you are getting lost. Trust me, as someone who used to think that mindfulness was too hard or was something that wouldn't work, it does. It makes you the boss of your thoughts. It's also super easy. It is something also that you build up, right?
正念实际上比反刍更强大，因为它是刻意的。反刍并不总是带有意图的。正念总是如此。这有点像你的大脑中存在一个优先级阶梯，优先处理重要想法，而刻意、有意识的想法总是会脱颖而出。正念就像是扮演父母的角色，是你大脑的父母，那个每当你在逃跑、每当你在迷失时把你带回来的父母。相信我，作为一个曾经认为正念太难或认为它不会起作用的人，它确实管用。它让你成为你思想的老板。这也超级简单。这也是一件你不断积累的事情，对吧？
starting with a minute, then going to a minute in one second, a minute and two seconds, three minutes, four minutes. It's a slow process. Mindfulness literally changes the structure of your brain. It changes how your brain is activated, what connections it seeks, how it thinks about problems. You know, that's incredibly powerful. That kind of ability to deliberately change, like, the neural wiring of your brain is sensational. At its core, you know, rumination is really a problem of uncontrolled attention.
从一分钟开始，然后到一分钟一秒，一分钟两秒，三分钟，四分钟。这是一个缓慢的过程。正念确实改变了你大脑的结构。它改变了你大脑的激活方式、它寻求的连接、它思考问题的方式。你知道，这真的非常强大。这种刻意改变大脑神经布线的能力是轰动性的。归根结底，你知道，反刍实际上是一个注意力失控的问题。
So whether it's mindfulness, meditation, grounding, essentially we want to make sure that our attention isn't only fixated on internal distress and repetitive thoughts. It has somewhere else to go. That there is control over our attention, you know, that we are making choices around what we want to focus on. And if we can do that, that's when we really are able to stop ruminating and just observe our thoughts, which I know I've said a million times, but also just like live with our thoughts. Let them be the little visitors in our head that we acknowledge, we say hi to, we don't panic about, we just let them exist without needing to read too much into them.
所以无论是正念、冥想还是扎根（grounding），本质上我们都希望确保我们的注意力不仅仅固定在内在的痛苦和重复的想法上。它还有别的地方可去。我们的注意力是受控的，你知道的，我们在围绕自己想要关注的事情做出选择。如果我们能做到这一点，那才是我们真正能够停止反刍并只是观察我们的想法的时候，我知道我已经说过一百万遍了，而且也只是像与我们的想法共存一样。让它们成为我们脑海中的小访客，我们承认它们，向它们问好，我们不惊慌，我们只是让它们存在，而不需要对它们做过多解读。
Okay, we're going to take a short break. I'm going to let us. some of those tips and tricks sit with you for a little while. When we come back, we have a few listener questions, some really good ones actually, around heartbreak, around intrusive thoughts, around so much more. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
好了，我们要休息一会儿。我要让你们把其中一些小贴士和技巧在心里消化一会儿。当我们回来时，我们有一些听众的问题，实际上是非常好的问题，关于心碎，关于侵入性想法，还有更多。所以请留下来。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养坚韧精神、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out, on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
以此看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾深信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰辛，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方的T-W-O-Persent。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your friends. girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的朋友、
The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed, I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《女朋友们》（The Girlfriends）这个新季节里，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack.
警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼不。我发誓，我将是他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA上拍了两次小金姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆到底有什么关系？
I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。每集我们挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的。包括最近一集请来马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），大谈80年代的快克（crack）。说清楚点，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize
我愿意一整天都聊快克，但只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现一条贯穿线。我们现在还在桌上讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年。真的吗？是的。
that we are in possession of the thing, and we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth,
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难成长》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Games）。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到
or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
我们已经拥有了这个东西，而我们还在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你发现作为一个好人很重要当你在这个世上时，
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. Okay, I'm back with some listener questions for this topic of rumination. For those of you who don't know, if you follow me on Instagram or follow the podcast on Instagram, I should say, at that psychology podcast. I often share the topics that we are going to be discussing in advance so you can ask any specific questions or dilemmas you may have around that topic or idea for me to answer in the episode. So you don't have to wait until after it comes out for any further questions. So make sure that
还是你成为一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地成为一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《艰难成长》中，就治愈、成长、父职、压力和目标进行真实的对话。
you are following me at that psychology podcast so you can participate. But for this, today's episodes, questions, let's start here. Hi, Gemma. Is it possible to positively ruminate or to make yourself only obsess over the good things in our life. I feel like if I could do that, I would be unstoppable. I love this question. And we haven't talked about it at all, which is my favorite kinds of questions when it's just like something completely different. So there is this book called the, I think it's called the Upward Spiral. And I'll admit I haven't finished it yet, but it focuses on exactly what you're talking about, the ability to, I guess, I think, guess ruminate only about positive things. Now, it's not rumination because rumination, the
打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《艰难成长》并立即收听。好的，我带着一些听众关于反刍这个主题的问题回来了。对于那些不知道的人，如果你在Instagram上关注我或者在Instagram上关注播客，我应该说，即that psychology podcast。我经常会提前分享我们要讨论的主题，这样你就可以问任何你可能对该主题或想法有的具体问题或困惑，以便我在节目中回答。所以你不必等到节目播出后才问更多问题。所以请确保
definition of it requires that the thought that we're obsessively thinking about, be distressing. It's basically, I don't know what other name to give it, but essentially, yes, you can. You can combat downward spirals or rumination with upward thought spirals, positive thought spirals, upward actions. It is possible to train your brain to loop and focus on the good. The thing is, is that it doesn't come as naturally as negative rumination. Our brains obviously have a built-in negativity bias, meaning we're wired to dwell on what's wrong as a way to learn from those moments and protect ourselves. But just like rumination makes us spiral over perceived failures, fears, moments of embarrassment, we can cultivate a kind of positive rumination by intentionally
你在关注that psychology podcast以便参与其中。但对于今天的节目问题，我们从这里开始。嗨，杰玛。有可能进行积极的反刍，或者让自己只痴迷于我们生活中的美好事物吗？我觉得如果我能做到这一点，我将不可阻挡。我喜欢这个问题。而且我们之前完全没有谈过这个，这是我最喜欢的那种问题，当它只是一些完全不同的事情时。所以有一本书叫，我想它叫《向上螺旋》（The Upward Spiral）。我承认我还没读完它，但它专注于你刚才谈到的事情，具备那种，我猜，我想，去只对积极的事情进行反刍的能力。现在，这不叫反刍，因为反刍，
revisiting our wins, moments of joy, things we're proud of, having like five minutes in our day where we just think about all the good things that have happened in our life, where we just think about everything that we are grateful for, deciding that for every ruminating thought, we have to have a positive thought, we have to list something that has brought us joy, having things like vision boards, positive affirmations or mantras on the background of our phone,
它的定义要求我们痴迷思考的想法必须是痛苦的。基本上，我不知道该给它起什么别的名字，但本质上，是的，你可以。你可以用积极的思想螺旋、积极的思想螺旋、积极的行动来对抗消极螺旋或反刍。训练你的大脑去循环并专注于美好是可能的。问题是，它不像消极反刍那样自然而然。我们的大脑显然具有内置的消极偏差，这意味着我们的天性就是去纠结哪里出了问题，以此作为从这些时刻中学习并保护自己的一种方式。但就像反刍让我们在感知到的失败、恐惧、尴尬时刻中陷入螺旋一样，我们可以通过刻意地
listening to really positive affirming music, listening to my other podcast mantra, if you would like, all of which can help us essentially have a more positive framework and way of relating to the world. The thing is, is that it is something that will take time. It is a conscious practice, a deliberate practice that you have to invest a lot of energy into, but you can be really successful with it. And the better you get out, the more time you spend making this a conscious thing that you do, the more that these positive thoughts will start to feel as natural,
重温我们的胜利、快乐的时刻、我们引以为豪的事情，在一天中有五分钟的时间只去想我们生活中发生的所有美好的事情，只去想我们感激的一切，决定每一个反刍的想法，我们都必须有一个积极的想法，我们必须列举出带给我们快乐的事物，拥有像愿景板、积极肯定语或手机背景上的座右铭之类的东西，
and self-reinforcing as some of the negative ones. So, excellent question. Moving on to our second question slash dilemma of the day, this question slash dilemma comes from Caroline. My biggest problem with rumination has been that it's made it very hard for me to get over someone. Specifically, my ex, someone I know wasn't right for me, but they keep popping into my head and I cannot stop myself going over and over mistakes, good moments, bad moments, even when it hurts.
听真正积极肯定音乐，如果你愿意的话，听我的另一个播客《Mantra》，所有这些都可以帮助我们本质上建立一个更积极的框架和与世界相处的方式。问题是，这需要时间。这是一个有意识的练习，一个你需要投入大量精力的刻意练习，但你可以取得巨大的成功。你在这方面做得越好，你花在把它变成你做的一件有意识的事情上的时间越多，这些积极的想法就会开始变得越自然，
Firstly, why do I do that when I know the relationship was wrong? And how can I stop myself? Ooh, Caroline, I know exactly what you are talking about. And honestly, I've always found it so strange that our brain chooses to punish itself in this way, especially around breakups, especially around the end of romantic love. It's like there's this bruise and we can't stop pressing it. it. Like we have to keep pressing it. Even when we know it hurts almost to remind ourselves that it hurts, it's super weird. Let me explain why this happens first. We tend to ruminate over people who
并且像一些消极的想法一样具有自我强化作用。所以，这是一个极好的问题。接下来是今天的第二个问题/困惑，这个由卡罗琳（Caroline）提出。我关于反刍最大的问题是，它让我很难放下一个人。具体来说是我的前任，一个我知道并不适合我的人，但他们一直不断地闯入我的脑海，我无法阻止自己一遍又一遍地回想错误、美好的时刻、糟糕的时刻，即使这很痛。
aren't right for us, not because we want them back necessarily, but because we are trying to find closure, specifically the closure our brains never got. Obviously, it relates back to that primary reason that we ruminate, to find a solution, to find comfort in our emotions, and to battle uncertainty. When a relationship ends, especially if it was a relationship that left you quite emotionally confused or left you with unmet needs or left you with resentment, your mind ends up kind of looping around and around and around. It ends up in looping mode. It searches for answers. It wants meaning. It wants a different ending. It wants closure because that packages up a thought that we have or an experience that we've had very neatly and allows it to kind of slot into place
首先，为什么在明知这段关系是错的情况下我还要这样做？我该如何阻止自己？噢，卡罗琳，我完全知道你在说什么。老实说，我一直觉得很奇怪，为什么我们的大脑选择以这种方式惩罚自己，尤其是在分手的时候，尤其是在浪漫爱结束的时候。这就像身上有一个瘀伤，我们就是忍不住去按它。就像我们必须一直去按它。即使我们知道它很痛，几乎是为了提醒自己它很痛，这超级奇怪。让我先解释一下为什么会发生这种情况。我们倾向于对那些
and make sense. So essentially the reason that this is happening is that you are trying to solve a puzzle that doesn't have a solution. The reason that your ex keeps popping into your head as well is because of these things called memory pops or memory flare-ups. Sometimes we just have random thoughts
不适合我们的人进行反刍，不一定是因为我们想让他们回来，而是因为我们试图寻找一个结果（closure），具体来说是我们的大脑从未得到的结果。显然，这可以追溯到我们反刍的主要原因：寻找解决方案，在情绪中寻找慰藉，以及对抗不确定性。当一段关系结束时，特别是如果这是一段让你在情感上感到困惑、留下未满足的需求或留下怨恨的关系，你的思维最终会不断地循环往复。它最终进入了循环模式。它在寻找答案。它想要意义。它想要一个不同的结局。它想要一个结果，因为这把我们有的想法或经历非常整洁地打包好，并允许它滑入正确的位置
that we don't want to have because energy is just shooting through our brain in weird ways. It's going down random pathways. It's, you know, we're rearranging neural circles. in the absence of this person and it means that all these memories and feelings are sometimes bubble to the surface. Sometimes as well you can have these memory flare-ups or memory pops around an anniversary, around a significant date, around a significant place or location or,
并变得有意义。所以本质上发生这种情况的原因是，你试图解开一个没有答案的谜题。你的前任不断闯入你的脑海，也是因为被称为记忆闪回（memory pops）或记忆井喷（memory flare-ups）的东西。有时我们只是会有随机的想法
you know, thing that you're visiting that reminds you of them. It's not in, it's not by any means indicative that you should get back together, that you made the wrong choice. It is just your brain trying to find an easy way to make sense of what is gone on and what has happened. The easiest way to combat this is obviously to try some of the things we've already suggested, but also to start engaging with more interesting things in your life. Start giving your brain something else to entertain it and think about because chances are, because of how emotionally salient and recent this experience was, it's probably the most interesting thing to your brain right now. Your brain is grasping onto the thing that's going to keep it
我们不想有，因为能量正以奇怪的方式穿过我们的大脑。它顺着随机的路径在走。它在，你知道的，我们在重新安排神经回路。在这个人缺席的情况下，这意味着所有这些记忆和感觉有时会浮出水面。有时你也会在周年纪念日、重要的日子、重要的地点或位置周围，或者
the most entertained. Change that. Give it something else that's entertaining. Keep busy. Find new hobbies. set a big post-relationship goal. Something that I do, my breakup routine, go and do every single doctor's appointment that you possibly can, that your insurance covers. Go to every life appointment, health appointment, I don't know, beauty appointment, anything that you haven't done in a while
你知道的，让你想起他们的事物周围，经历这些记忆井喷或记忆闪回。这绝不意味着你应该复合，你做出了错误的选择。这只是你的大脑试图找到一种简单的方法来理解已经逝去和已经发生的事情。对抗这一点的最简单方法显然是尝试我们已经建议过的一些事情，但同时也要开始参与你生活中更有趣的事情。开始给你的大脑一些其他东西来娱乐它和思考，因为很有可能，由于这段经历在情感上的显著性和近期性，它可能是你大脑现在最有趣的事情。你的大脑正在抓住那个能让它
and just fill your calendar with self-improvement, with recognizing your potential, with taking care of yourself. Also really worth having a powerful affirmation or a mantra that you can come back to that will soothe you something like, I know that true love won't pass me. I know that there is a lesson in this that I may have to learn. I know this is just expanding me as a person.
保持最大娱乐性的事情。改变它。给它一些其他有趣的事情。保持忙碌。寻找新的爱好。设定一个巨大的后关系目标。我常做的一件事，我的分手日常，就是去做每一个你保险能涵盖的医生预约。去参加每一个生活预约、健康预约、我不知道，美容预约，任何你有一段时间没做过的事情，
Just something, a touchstone, a phrase to come back to, to help keep you grounded. Also worthwhile to listen to a whole episode that I did on this titled, How to Get Over Someone You Can't Stop Thinking About. It's basically an hour long answer to this question. So good luck. I hope you get through it. All right.
然后用自我提升、认识自己的潜力、照顾好自己来填满你的日程表。也超级值得拥有一个强大的肯定语或座右铭，你可以回到它身边来安抚自己，比如：我知道真爱不会与我擦肩而过。我知道这其中有一个我可能需要学习的教训。我知道这只是让我作为一个人得到拓展。
I think we only have time for one more question today, only three questions for this episode, but this one I really, really liked. How do you tell the difference between ruminating and just reflecting or trying to proactively problem solve? I feel like I think about things a lot, but it's not always necessarily bad. Sometimes it's very useful. This is a difficult distinction. You know, we talked about it before how rumination has this tricky way of convincing
只是一些东西，一个基准，一个可以回到的短语，来帮助你保持脚踏实地。也很值得听一听我做的一整集关于这个主题的节目，标题是《如何放下你无法停止思念的人》（How to Get Over Someone You Can't Stop Thinking About）。这基本上是对这个问题长达一小时的回答。所以祝你好运。我希望你能度过难关。好的，
you that it's actually problem solving when it's not. the way to really tell the difference between rumination and problem solving or reflection comes down to, I think, the intention around it and the emotional impact. Rumination is repetitive, emotionally charged. It's also quite distressing and there isn't really a resolution contained in it. There's often a real emotional impact that is rooted in fear, regret, self-blame, anxiety, And the more you ruminate, the worse you tend to feel. Whereas when you are trying to actively work through something and problem solve,
我想我们今天只有时间再回答一个问题了，这集只有三个问题，但我真的真的很喜欢这一个。你怎么区分反刍与单纯的反思或试图积极解决问题？我觉得我对事情想得很多，但它并不一定总是坏事。有时它非常有用。这是一个很难区分的界限。你知道，我们之前讨论过反刍是如何以一种狡猾的方式说服
the more you think about something, the more you work through something, the better it feels. There is progress there. Healthy reflection is more curious, it's more constructive, and there isn't as much pain. When you reflect on something and go back to it, often the resolution is that you do feel better. you leave a moment of intense thinking with more clarity, with more peace, with some kind of insight or shift in perspective.
你认为它实际上是在解决问题，而事实并非如此。真正区分反刍与解决问题或反思的区别，归根结底，我认为在于其背后的意图和情感影响。反刍是重复的、充满情绪的。它也相当痛苦，其中并没有真正的解决方案。它通常具有扎根于恐惧、遗憾、自责、焦虑的真正情感影响，你反刍得越多，你的感觉往往就越糟糕。然而，当你试图积极解决某事和解决问题时，
So the way to really tell the difference is, are you leaving one of these moments in feeling better or are you feeling worse? Do you feel like you have somewhere or some kind of solution to do or to follow or to pursue or do you not? do you feel like your thinking is action-orientated or is just looping? I think that's really the important distinction. Hopefully that answered your question. I hope as well that this episode was useful to you. If you have made it this far, please leave an emoji that you think indicates overthinking, thought spiraling, and rumination in general.
你对某事思考得越多，你对某事的处理就越多，感觉就会越好。那里有进展。健康的的反思更多是好奇的，更具建设性的，也没有那么多的痛苦。当你反思某事并回到它身边时，通常的解决方法是你确实感觉更好了。你带着更多的清晰度、更多的平静、某种洞察力或视角转变离开一段激烈的思考时刻。
mine is definitely like the wave emoji not like the hand wave the ocean wave emoji because I feel like that is exactly what rumination feels like you like pop your head above the water and you're like oh I think I figured this out and then it's like smash like your back down so hopefully you don't you feel less like that because of this episode and that you've learned something you can apply something make sure to send this episode to someone who you think could benefit from it a sibling a colleague a friend a partner someone in your life who might remember a little bit too much. Leave a five-star review wherever you are listening.
所以真正分辨的方法是，你离开这些时刻时感觉更好了还是更糟了？你觉得你有一些地方或某种解决方案可以去做、去遵循、去追求，还是没有？你觉得你的思维是行动导向的还是只是在循环？我认为这真的是重要的区别。希望这回答了你的问题。我也希望这一集对你有所帮助。如果你听到了这里，请留下一个你认为能表明过度思考、思维螺旋和普遍反刍的表情符号，
It does really help others discover the podcast. Make sure that you are following along and that you're following me on Instagram as well at that psychology podcast again for like the 50th time in this episode. If you want to be able to submit listener questions or just see what's coming up, what's happening in the psychology of your 20s space. Until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. And remember, you are not your thoughts. thoughts. Talk soon.
我的一定是海浪的表情符号，不是挥手的那个，而是海浪的表情符号，因为我觉得这正是反刍的感觉，你把头探出水面，心想“哦，我想我把这个想通了”，然后“啪”的一声，你又被拍回水底。所以希望因为这集节目，你这种感觉少了一些，并且你学到了一些东西，你可以应用一些东西。确保把这集节目发送给你认为能从中受益的人，兄弟姐妹、同事、朋友、伴侣，你生活中可能想得有点太多的人。在你收听的任何地方留下五星好评。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHard. Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
这确实对其他人发现这个播客很有帮助。确保你一直在关注，并且在Instagram上关注我，同样是that psychology podcast，在这集里已经是第50次提到了。如果你想提交听众问题，或者只是看看心理学20多岁领域即将发生什么，正在发生什么。下次见，保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。记住，你不是你的想法。回头见。
84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year.
2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养坚韧精神、体能和抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰辛，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方的TWO%。在《回顾过去》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我是个大时刻。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
84年对我很重要。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每集我们挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，并与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起，试图弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。
Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯带来的《艰难成长》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起进行这些对话。多少男人带着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习艰难成长。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦斯女士，你对这个特定测试作假了两次，对吧？我对测试作了一次假。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱网》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱网》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。